[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Trevor Johns.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on the Android team.
Let's take a bit to talk about
how to do network service
discovery on Android.
So what is network service
discovery?
So say that you have a game and
you want to let friends
play with each other.
One approach is to get email
addresses for everyone in the
game and use that to set up
a shared room on a server
somewhere in the cloud.
It's not a bad approach,
especially if you're going to
be competing with someone
far away.
But if all your friends are
sitting right next to, all
those email addresses are
going to get a bit
inconvenient.
Wouldn't it be great if you
could just find nearby users
who also happen to have
your app just based on
the physical proximity?
This is where network service
discovery, or NSD, comes into
the picture.
NSD lets your app find other
devices on the local network
that support services you're
interested in.
Those services could be
physical devices like
printers, webcams, HTTP servers,
and, yes, even games.
In a sense, it terms any
local network into a
social network for apps.
Take this game here, which uses
NSD to place everyone on
the same subnet into a
virtual waiting room.
It's a quick way
to form teams.
Once discovered, you'll then be
able to connect directly to
any of those apps using
the standard
Android networking stack.
So let's go into a bit
more details about
how all this works.
And then I'll show you how to
implement the code for all of
this inside of your app.
NSD is based on two
protocols--
DNS-SD and multicast DNS.
The SD stands for service
discovery.
Like DNS on the internet, this
provides a mapping between
human friendly host names--
so, say, myphone.local--
and the IP address where
that device lives.
Now normally you'd go to
something like google.com.
In this case, everything is
going to be ending in
something.local because it's
on the local subnet.
That's how the device can
distinguish between devices
advertised via multicast DNS and
devices advertised using
the global DNS system.
So unlike traditional DNS,
MDNS is completely
distributed, which means
no central server.
Devices communicate amongst
themselves to build a network
directory of services.
Since it's based on multicast,
it only works between devices
on the same broadcast domain.
So such as a LAN.
It also requires the network
supports multicast traffic,
which some businesses
or university
networks might disable.
But it should work without
problems on most home
networks, or even small
business networks.
DNS-SD extends multicast DNS to
provide service discovery,
listing what hosts implement
specific protocols.
Many people think of DNS
exclusively in the context of
mapping host names
to IP addresses.
But DNS is actually general,
if somewhat limited,
hierarchical database.
It can store almost
any kind of data
for almost any purpose.
So service names in this case
will take the form of
service.transport.local.
This is how we're mapping from
a service name to what you
traditionally think of
as a domain name.
So in this case, we're
using myapp.tcp.
myapp is the service name.
And tcp is the network transport
that we're using.
Clients can then go and query
on this name to retrieve the
listing of devices
supporting it.
Once a desired device is
selected, the IP address, port
number, and any other necessary
metadata are
requested via DNS service
or SRV records.
Since we're using multicast
DNS rather than the usual
internet DNS infrastructure,
there's no need to go and
register these domains within
any registrar or pay money.
You can just simply broadcast
them to network peers as
they're needed.
Now that said, it's still a
good idea to register your
service name with the IANA to
prevent any name collisions.
There's a free service
iana.org that
will let you do this.
Now we've gone over the protocol
details, let's talk
about using the NSD APIs on
Android to broadcast your
app's custom service.
The good news is you don't need
to worry about most of
the protocol details since the
OS takes care of almost
everything for you.
So before you start, let's say
that we have our app listening
on an available port.
This is just the code that you
typically use to open up a
socket on Android.
But notice that we're
not explicitly
selecting a port here.
Be careful to never hardcode
your port number when you're
using NSD, since other apps
could be using the same port
number as your app.
Instead, we'll ask the
system to give us a
random unused port.
This is OK though, because
we're going to go and
advertise this to other devices
so they'll be able to
discover which port you're
listening on.
So, now we have a service
listening for traffic on our
device, we'll want to register
that on the local network.
The first thing to do
is to create an NSD
service info object.
This object provides all the
information that other devices
on the network will use when
they're deciding whether or
not to connect to your
device or not.
The service type, again,
uniquely identifies the
service your phone
is advertising.
So something like appname.tcp.
And you'll typically put an
underscore in front of each
section as a matter
of convention.
The service name uniquely
identifies a particular
instance of your app.
So this is not the service
type, the service name.
Now with the service name, it's
usually a good idea to
use the device's Bluetooth name,
just as something that's
nice and human friendly.
It should be unique.
But if not, it's
not a big deal.
Android we go and append a
number to the end of the name
to correct that error.
Finally, we'll set the port
number that we selected above
so that other apps know which
port we selected.
Calling register service,
finally, will inform the OS
about the new service.
And Android will take care of
broadcasting that information
out to other devices
as needed.
At the end here there's a
registration listener, which
is a set of call backs, like on
service registered, that'll
let us know about the success or
failure of this operation.
We're going to see this pattern
a lot over the next
few slides.
The important thing to notice
here is on service registered,
which is where our app can go
and store the service name.
Even though we set this when
registering, the OS might have
changed it to resolve a conflict
from another device
in the network.
Remember I said that
the service name
always has to be unique.
So this is your chance to go and
discover if it wasn't and
update your UI if needed.
You might want to go and show
the service name to the user.
Not all apps do though.
So this might or might not
be of interest to you.
Now that our app is registered,
let's take a look
at how to issue a query
to find other devices.
Service discovery, like service
registration, has two steps--
setting up a discovery listener
with the relevant
call backs and making a single
asynchronous API call to
discover services.
Let's work backwards.
We'll start with the call
to discover services.
Here you'll pass in the service
name that you're
interested in.
So again, something
like myapp.tcp.
The name of the discovery
protocol to use, which is
always DNS-SD--
again, this is not the
protocol of your app.
It's the service discovery
protocol.
And right now Android only
supports DNS-SD.
So this argument will always
be protocol DNS-SD.
And finally, a discovery
listener object, which is what
we'll use to get the results
of this discovery process.
The listener will get a call
back for each device found.
And of course there's callbacks
where your app can
handle any errors found.
The important method here is
on service found, which is
where we're going to find out
about all the services and the
devices that we're potentially
interested in and store them
in the list.
This is the list that you'll
typically present to the user.
And that will let them pick
which devices that they want
to connect to.
So once we know which devices we
want to connect to, we call
resolve service.
This is another asynchronous
call.
It's a little bit expensive.
So again, we have a listener
that's going to go and get the
results of this.
And this is where we find out
the IP address and port number
of the device that we
want to connect to.
Once you get that information,
then we're just going to go
ahead and connect
to it directly
using a standard socket.
Now, before you go off and play
your game, there's one
last thing you want to do.
When your application exits,
it is very important to
unregister your service so
that the OS will stop
advertising it to
other devices.
To do this, call NSD manager's
unregister service method
whenever your application's
onDestroy or onPause method
gets called.
You'll also want to make sure to
call stop service discovery
since the discovery process is
also a bit expensive, and we
don't want to leave that
running unchecked.
And that's it.
You're all set to use network
service discovery to find
other copies of your
app on the network.
Happy networking.